Film Courage: This may be an old wives’
tale about unhappy writers having more depth
in which to write about, more in which to
pull from? Whereas the happy writer is just
scratching the surface and it might be too
much of a movie of the week instead of something
that pulls at your emotional core and you
can put yourself in the character’s shoes?
I don’t know, can we dispel this (that you
have to be unhappy)?
Dr. Ken Atchity, Producer/Author: This is
a famous dilemma that people have been talking
about my whole lifetime. A book came out a
few years ago calledThe Drama of the Gifted
ChildbyAlice Miller. It’s a very interesting
book and it basically says that writers should
fear therapy because it might therapize, it
might take away their angst from which came
all their brilliant ideas. And it’s simply
not true because there are just too many examples
of productive writers who have plenty of angst
and one of my favorite examples isStephen
Kingwho published inmy magazine Dreamworks.
We sent out a letter to artists all over the
world including him.
Could you please tell us whether dreams have
any influence on your creativity and if so,
give us an example of a dream and a creative
work that came from it?
SoFellinisent us a cartoon that he dreamed
in the middle of the night that led to8
1/2(his movie) and we got great stuff from
all kinds of people. And Stephen King six
months later after everyone else sent us a
very short letter and said:
This is my constant nightmare. I am sitting
alone in the attic typing away and a little
door in the floor of the attic opens and a
hideous face comes out of the floor and I
start typing as fast as I can because the
faster I type the more the door closes and
if I slow down the face keeps coming out.
And then he says:
Does that count?
And it’s an example of what you’re talking
about because he has plenty of angst going
on. He has plenty of terror and fear and dark
things in some of his most brilliant work
like theSHAWSHANK REDEMPTIONandTHE SHINING.
And he’s not an unhappy writer. He knows
that he needs to put the time in every day
and he’s figured it out and he’s prolific
and so on.
So there are just too many examples of balanced
writers, let’s call them mentally balanced
writers. One of my favorite statements from
the world of art isSalvador Daliwho saidThe
difference between myself and a madman is
that I am not mad.And I love that because
only an artist who knows how close sanity
he is to insanity knows what that means. Like
he’s one of those mad men who is not mad.
Whereas a lot of other mad men are mad. And
okay, they kill themselves or they kill somebody
else.
And so it’s all about knowing yourself,
it’s all about how your mind works and proving
it and testing it until you look back and
you goMy gosh I’ve written all these books.
I’ve got all these things going on. And
I don’t think I’m crazy and on the other
hand I don’t think I’m sane either.It’s
like you’ve just figured it out and it doesn’t
mean that you’re not having dark spells.
It’s just that you kind of look at your
dark spells from the outside instead of from
the inside.
It’s very common in meditation and yoga
to understand that you can either be inside
yourself all the time and drive yourself crazy
by letting your mind run it (what’s going
on). Or you can stay above your mind by all
these thoughts going by and all this stuff
and recognize that you (the one looking) is
in charge, not all of the thoughts.
AndA Writer’s Timehas all these theories
about how the creative mind works which is
what I call themanaging editor,looking
at the fight going on inside your mind and
realizing that this can be controlled if you
trick the two sides of the mind and force
them to work together. That’s kind of what
it’s all about to become happy and productive
at the same time and it seems to work for
a lot of people.